welcome to the Larry Arn show I would be
that man Larry yarn this is the first
edition of that show and I've got a
spectacular guest because the guest is
in politics I will say at the outset
that Hillsdale College is not a partisan
Institution
except that it loves the Constitution
the United States and limited government
of which it is a creature and has been
from its beginning in 1844.
I'm proud to have our guest today
because he's important and he's
important because he knows things and he
does things
that are remarkable in our politics
today
uh welcome Governor it's great to be
here my first time I wanted to come
we've talked about it for a long time so
I'm glad we finally got it done yeah
High Time
um I want to talk about you've got a
book out called courage to be free
interesting that it takes courage to be
free but it always has and especially
now today and it begins with a
discussion of a man that I met first in
1974 by the name of Angelo codavilla
yeah I will tell you that the book is in
the mood of
the decline of the Roman Republic
you call the government we have today
the regime
you call the
media the praetorian guard
those are Grim words if you know that
history is that where you think we are
well I think that part of the book is
juxtaposing the success of Florida uh
with the decline of our country and I
noticed this when I was running for
re-election that Floridians were really
happy to be Floridians they were really
happy about the direction of the state
but they were so incredibly pessimistic
about the direction of the country about
what was going on not just in DC but
with the elites on our society more
broadly yes in the corporate press Wall
Street all these other places and it
causes you to kind of take a step back
survey what's the America was like when
I was growing up I mean I kind of
graduated high school in the in the late
90s and we were probably the most
powerful country in the history of the
world or certainly one of them there we
were really at our Peak and it seems
like over the last 20 plus years we've
stubbed our toe time and time again and
we're not as strong as we were then and
there's a lot of reasons for that uh I
think some of the behavior of our ruling
class is is first among them but there
are other things and so yes the country
is not doing well but I think that there
is a positive aspect of the book to just
show that what we put together in
Florida shows that all the different
folks who are making things worse in the
country those are the same folks we beat
time and time again on all these issues
in Florida and we've now become the
Citadel of freedom in the United States
well the book certainly is a very
hopeful but but we're not ready to go
there yet we're going to talk about all
the bad stuff first uh tell us about
this ruling class who are they and what
makes them what they are well I think
Cota Villa was really the first to
really crystallize this for me he wrote
an essay probably 10 12 years ago at
this point and what he pointed out was
these are folks in in different organs
of society it's not like a conspiracy or
anything but they all have the same
basic assumptions about the way the
world should operate about how they
should be able to exercise power over
other people and so that is really the
the governing ideology not just of our
bureaucracy not just of our elected
class but even people in High Finance
and the media and all this and so it
creates kind of an elite Cadre across
institutions and then you kind of have
the rest of us who feel differently and
and we're kind of the the country folk
uh it's different and I think he pointed
this out you know if you were a hundred
years ago you would have been if you're
a Northeastern business guy all those
people kind of thought the same there
were big Regional differences in the
country and I think with the Advent of
kind of progressive ideology affecting
all these institutions a lot of those
differences are now muted because
they're United by their overall leftism
somehow ever able to act together uh in
some ways the country do you think is
more centralized than it used to be
National media big engines of search and
all that stuff
uh what do you do about that
well I think just in the in my adult
lifetime that's true I mean when big
Tech came on the scene it was very
liberating in many respects uh it was a
way to get around the Legacy Media and
you could communicate ideas uh that has
changed in the last five or ten years
where Tech Works in concert uh with the
bureaucracy uh to be able to limit
information so we saw this during
covid-19 when fauci is talking with
Facebook about what is quote
misinformation of course everything they
said was misinformation is basically
things that ended up being true whether
that the virus came from the lab whether
it's at the cloth masks were ineffective
all these different things and so yes
you have more people in high positions
of authority working in concert to be
able to advance an agenda and that's
just I think an agenda that is not in
the best interest of the majority of the
people of our country
you quote Madison you quote the founders
a lot accurately whenever the real power
in a government wherever the real power
in the government lies there is danger
of Oppression
wherever there is an interest in power
to do wrong wrong will generally be done
and not less readily by a powerful and
interested party than by a powerful and
interested Prince
uh is that what we have now we have a a
people who
think they can control elections and
think that they're in the right and if
you oppose them they will prosecute you
well certainly I think the difference
between maybe how government operates
today and say when President Reagan came
on the scene President Reagan said the
most dangerous words in the English
language ROM from the government and I'm
here to help and it was true but a lot
of that was kind of central planning run
amok these were do-gooders that thought
they could socially engineer Society of
course it didn't work and So Reagan
pointed that out I think now it's a much
sharper use of government Authority I do
think that they conceive of themselves
as representing one faction of society
against and other factions of society
and so you see dissimilar treatment of
people I saw this my first year in
Congress when the IRS targeting Scandal
happened they were going after these
little conservative groups even in my
district these groups of citizens and so
so I think that that's something that's
significant I also think that
concentration of power the founders were
really concerned about government power
I think they'd be surprised at the
extent to which these private companies
are exercising de facto Public Power
really I think on behalf of the regime
and whether that's the the banks
colluding to do things like ESG whether
that's Tech colluding to sensor you know
that's power being exercise in ways that
are not accountable to the electorate
and so here's a delicate thing and I
think a very bold thing
um
it requires The Prudent use of political
power
to break up these centers of power in
politics and outside that are oppressing
people
can you do that safely
well I don't know that we have any other
choice but to try I mean if you think
about it what we have now is you know I
can win an election in Florida by a
million and a half votes and yet if I'm
not diligent about protecting my people
the left can still impose their agenda
through universities through Corporate
America through tech companies through
the federal bureaucracy and so I think
someone in my position you know I've got
to be able to use my constitutional
authority to be able to safeguard the
liberty of my citizens not just against
my own government getting out of hand
that's easy for me to do but also
against all these other arteries of
society that have been infected by
people that don't have their best
interests at heart
in your book you identify Congress as
the mainstream of government because it
makes the laws and you say that the hope
is with them
uh
effectively you say that you're not
saying those words
uh what's wrong with Congress you were
in the Congress so if you go back and
you know this well the Federalist 51
articulated that the premise of our
constitution by having separate branches
and having the ability to check each
other was that ambition would counteract
the ambition you're the executive by
human nature you want to expand your
power I'm in the Congress it's human
nature we want our our Branch to be the
most powerful so you'd be fighting back
and forth what's happened with the
modern Congress is their desire to
remain in office has inverted that to
where it's easier for them to remain in
office if they punt on all these
important issues so they would rather
draft vague legislation that punts the
critical decisions to the bureaucracy so
that they have plausible deniability in
a re-election campaign they would rather
keep the government going on autopilot
rather than use the power of the person
a way that would that would provoke a
confrontation with the executive because
they don't want to quote government
shutdown and they don't want to quote be
blamed for a government shutdown so I
think the modern Congress has put its
individual members desire to remain in
office and perpetuity ahead of the
institution's prerogatives to be what
should be the most powerful branch of
the government because you could have a
runaway executive Congress can just
simply not fund those activities and it
stops and so unless Congress is taking
affirmative action to keep the
government doing these things those
those behaviors will cease but they just
don't have the gumption to be able to do
it so I wouldn't say I'm hopeful that
that will change I do think that there's
a bigger recognition at least amongst
Republicans who are in Congress now that
it has to change because otherwise what
the bureaucracy you know you know people
we called a deep State people so it's a
conspiracy there's not a conspiracy
theory when there's no constitutional
accountability you're going to have
power
accumulate and it's going to be wielded
in ways that are going to be detrimental
that's that's basically 101 from what
our Founders thought so they need to get
serious about exercising their Authority
and I think the Decades of them
defaulting on that responsibility have
led to where we are now
uh you mentioned a few things that
Executives can do to turn that around
sounds like you've done some of them can
you what are those well look at the
federal level uh well so one of the
things I did when I became Governor is I
had my my staff in the transition give
me a as a compiler book of every
possible Authority I have constitutional
statutory customary powers that may have
been used what are my Powers vis-a-vis
local government because I've removed
local government officials what about
the legislature so I had all that and so
you're like okay what levers can you
pull to advance an agenda and I think in
at the federal Level under article two
you know there are certain levers that
can be pulled I mean I talk about in the
book how one way to deal with the
bureaucracy is to take all the employees
who exercise policy making decisions and
classify them as a different schedule
under federal civil service where
they're not they don't have the Ironclad
protections so that they can be removed
I mean after all if you are making these
judgments Article 2 says the executive
the elected president has the has the
right to wield executive power if you're
making policy judges that are
undercutting that you should be shown
the door that would need to be put in
obviously it would be challenged by the
left uh and then I also think and we
just had a judge um in the fifth Circuit
Judge ho write a concurrence saying we
need to determine whether Article 2 is
is improperly circumscribed by some of
these Civil Service laws because if you
think about it right now what we have is
a republican get elected president and
the left still controls the the organs
of the executive branch that's not the
way the Constitution was designed it's
one thing to have a civil service
protection if I'm like some somebody in
the bowels of the bureaucracy and you're
working for me maybe I can't just fire
you at will but to have that apply to
the elected president where they can't
make changes to be able to effectuate
their agenda that's not the way it's
done now the Democrats love it because
they're in charge no matter what happens
the way this has gone on for the last 20
30 years
could that you call that schedule F in
your book can can can the president do
that well I think this was something in
the previous administration that a lot
of us were hoping for uh I think they
tried to do it maybe at the very end it
just didn't it didn't really get off the
ground but but yeah I think I think you
can do it I think it'll be litigated but
I think there are members on the U.S
Supreme Court now who've seen the way
this bureaucracy is is operating and
they and I think they'll recognize I
think the majority of the Court will
recognize that's not consistent with the
original understanding of the
Constitution
you mentioned the number of fifty
thousand yeah
that's a few yeah
make a difference I know a lot of people
who've worked in the executive branch uh
in the in DC
uh
it's a fearsome thing to do
because people are out to get you no
question
um they can hurt you but I think that
some of this has been there's always
been an assumption that there's nothing
you can do about it there's always been
an assumption for example that agencies
like the doj and FBI are quote
independent that's like Washington Speak
oh these are these are independent
president can't be involved in those
agencies and when they say that doj and
FBI are independent what they're saying
is they think they should be
unaccountable so these are the agencies
that can imprison you arrest and
imprison you and they shouldn't be
accountable to the one person elected in
that Branch give me a break so I think
Republican uh executive in particular
you know you've got to be exercising
proper oversight and holding those
agencies personally accountable you
can't just say that they're independent
and hands off you can't do anything
that's not the way the system's design I
had a I almost afraid to tell the story
I know somebody who was senior in the
FBI he was retired now
and I was talking to him and I wouldn't
talk to him about the FBI really and as
he was leaving I said I hope you're not
mixed up in all that
and he said I'm just trying to keep the
FBI independent
and I said independent of what
and he said nobody ever asked me that
question before
you see and they're these people care
million dollar question and I think what
they'll try to say is well we want it to
be independent of quote politics and yes
is it appropriate for an elected
executive to say FBI I don't like this
person you go you go of course not
that's an abuse of power but it's wholly
appropriate to go bring in the FBI drugs
hey wait a minute all these BLM rioters
how come none of them have been held
accountable how come you're going after
these people and not these people you
absolutely could do that and you should
do that and if they don't have a good
answer the FBI director should be fired
and you should put someone else in there
and I I sometimes think I've been saying
this for years
I resent you just a little bit because
you figured out quicker than I did a
whole bunch of stuff but um
uh I've been saying for years don't the
people understand that the only ones who
really answer to them are the ones they
vote for that's right shouldn't they be
in authority and I talk a little bit
about the books you know I was a U.S
congressman for three terms and
most of what my constituents would
contact my office about had nothing to
do with what I was voting on or anything
that was before the Congress it was
action that had been taken against them
or pending action in some new rule or
something from the bureaucracy so
they're coming to me for help for what
the executive branch is basically doing
without any prompting from Congress
they're just deciding they want to do a
new rule or something and I'm like gee
it's not really the way it should be I
mean these constituents should be coming
to Congress asking the congressmen about
different things that Congress is doing
but instead all the action was done via
executive agencies I want to talk to you
about the pandemic for a minute uh
I know I have these three guys I call
them my three Geniuses uh Jay
bhattacharya Martin koldorf and Scott
Atlas and you worked with at least two
of them yourself
and you went through a process that was
just like the one I went through here
that is I wanted to figure out if the
people around here were going to be
harmed by this virus
and I wasn't prepared just to listen to
the constantly shifting things from the
CDC and the
Michigan governor
and health department
and so I started trying to find out and
I found out pretty quick that it's
extremely unlikely that this virus would
hurt a young person
and so then that that liberated
something you know because here the kids
live in dormitories you can't keep them
apart also they walk around with a sense
of immortality all the time you can't
make them afraid either you don't really
want to unless it's right
so we kept the college open
you kept Florida open
and how did you do that explain that
well a lot of it was in fact I dealt
with all I consulted with all three of
those guys and they're all really good
and then looking at the data myself I
mean covid was potentially an
existential threat for the State of
Florida for two reasons one we have so
many elderly people we have almost 4 000
long-term care facilities throughout our
state we've got Condominiums up and down
the coast particularly in Southern
Florida where a lot of elderly people
are there so a virus that impacts
elderly disproportionately impacts
Florida disproportionately also to the
extent this was disrupting the economy
we rep Hospitality tourism is our bread
and butter that would be a huge economic
threat to the state and so for both of
those you know so we took it very very
seriously what I started looking at was
okay they say the hospitals are going to
be overwhelmed unless you know we we
shut down Society so they give you these
models and these graphs all the
governors were getting them and then I'm
watching every day and it didn't quite
you know match what they were saying so
like by April 10th they said Florida is
going to have a hundred thousand coveted
patients and in reality I think we had
like maybe like 3 000 or something like
that I'm like okay this is something's
wrong here and so what I I came to the
realization of you know low impact on on
non-elderly particularly kids uh kids
were not necessarily transmitting it
more because there was initially a fear
about getting kids together in school
that it would be like the flu where all
of a sudden it starts spreading more so
a lot of the elderly didn't want the
kids in school and I took Flack when we
had that because they were concerned
about how the kids would spread it but
it turns out they really weren't doing
that the hospitals I was confident we'd
have enough hospital room and then
bhattacharya did a thing in Stanford
where he looked at the antibodies
because what we were doing like CD you
test somebody you're positive I may have
had covid and not had anything severe
and never tested it so that wasn't
showing up so by doing the antibodies
what bhattacharya and his team showed
was actually it is much more it had
spread much more than what we thought
but it was also so less lethal than we
thought so that to me was like okay the
appropriate course is to help the
vulnerable Focus whatever protection on
nursing homes on elderly you know with
testing whatever they need but you have
to have Society functioning and you
can't just be in a Perpetual state of
paralysis and basically what fauci said
I think was mid April of 2020 they said
well when can States open back up he
said when there's no cases and no deaths
well that's impossible there was no way
you were going to eradicate it by doing
that and so I was like that is not going
to work we've got to go our own way and
you know a lot of it was people like Jay
and them they were not given any
recognition they were actually smeared
by people like fauci for for speaking
the truth so that so the difficult thing
just I think as an executive is and why
a lot of Governors went different than
me it's always easier politically to
just defer to the medical people say
well fauci's saying this so that or this
this health bureaucrats saying that so
when I was making these decisions you
know they were very unpopular with the
media with the bureaucracy with the left
and even some Republicans you know were
attacking me and I did not necessarily
have that much medical backing not
because it wasn't sound no one was
willing to speak out except a few of
those guys and and just the hysteria
that it developed so I think that was
that was a difficult part of it but
ultimately you know after we went on
went on our way people started looking
and they're like okay
Florida's not doing worse than New York
they're not doing worse than any of
these and so we really started to pick
up once people realized I think part of
it was there was so much fear in society
so that really subsided and then we
became very quickly a magnet for people
all over the country to come to visit to
move you name it and our economy
probably in the last couple years has
done as good as we've ever done in the
history of the State of Florida and
we've had more wealth move into Florida
since covet than has ever moved into a
single state in U.S history even
adjusted for inflation
uh
and an entire nation to its homes
that I I uh you know what so first of
all it was it was good for me it was
good for you I can see
I had some responsibilities here
I'm supposed to have college and you
know if the kids are all going to die
then you can't have college but I was
supposed to find out about that and and
then it was also apparent to me the cost
of this because kids are young and take
a year and a half out of their life
that's an enormous thing
and and very destructive I mean we've
seen this in these universities
particularly in New England how they
were isolating these college students
and it led to more depression I do
believe it led to more suicides and in
Florida what I told the universities was
do not police their social life I was
like these kids need to be kids they're
going to go out guess what a lot of them
will get covered no one will go to the
hospital and then it'll be gone in six
weeks in terms of going through the pot
and that's exactly what happened I think
we had in the first semester First full
semester 2020 uh in the fall I think
there was like one or two
hospitalizations in our University
system and I don't I think covet was
incidental to the hospitalization so the
cost of con restricting these kids was
so much greater than whatever risk they
were assuming by living their lives and
I'll tell you to this day I will have
people come up to me saying you know you
saved my college experience you saved
our senior year like I think like the
fact that they were able to do school a
lot of it a lot of the professors wanted
to do remote and so the schools were I
think probably a little bit too
accommodating on that and that first
semester back but the fact that they
could live a normal life was huge and it
was a stark contrast to what we saw
throughout most of the United States
elections uh
it's a fact of the American government
that it is the first purely
representative government ever built
that means
whoever is The Sovereign doesn't run any
part of the government
they control them but James Madison
writes that in the 63rd Federalist uh
that means that the only way we have to
control the government is through
elections and elections are very
controversial now and they're regulated
in new ways that that worry me
so what have you done in Florida to make
sure elections are fair well we've done
a number of things so when I became
Governor we removed some of the
supervisors in South Florida with my
removal power because they had been
bungling elections for a long time and
got better people in there and those ran
very well in 2020 as a result of us
doing that we also have done things like
ban ballot harvesting we've banned the
use of Zucker bucks which Zuckerberg
pioneered in 2020 where they would have
private money through non-profit groups
they'd give money directly to election
offices so like a county election that
administers the election would get
millions in Zucker bucks and then the
organization would send political
operatives to work in that office and
say you know you've got to do mail
ballots you've got to do ballot
harvesting you've got to do all those
stuff so they basically commandeered the
Machinery of the election for partisan
purposes now they didn't say it was for
partisan but they were going to Democrat
areas and doing that so we've banned the
use of private money we also don't allow
mass mailing of unsolicited ballots in
the mail if you want an apps T ballot
Florida's had this for many decades you
can request you got to show ID now and
then they'll send you one and then
verify your signature on the back end
but just to send all these millions of
ballots and just floating around in the
ether is a real real problem so we put
the kibosh on that but the thing is is
you can have violations of election law
are they actually going to be prosecuted
so we created an office in state
government the office of election crime
so this is actually an office that will
investigate and they can bring charges
with it through the Attorney General's
office so we've brought charges against
people who were illegally in the country
and voted who voted in multiple
jurisdictions and had been con some had
been convicted of serious crimes and are
therefore ineligible to vote so we were
able to do that in 2022 and it made an
great impact on the 2022 election just
in the sense of we didn't have really
any problems I mean because I had these
guys I'm like look for any problems you
see not that it affected my race I mean
we were fine but I wanted to see what
happened and I think just the fact that
people knew look it's not worth
violating the election law why would you
want to get prosecuted for voting if
you're not if you're not eligible to
vote so so we really I think the fact
that we had legal reforms but then the
credible uh mechanism to actually hold
people accountable caused us to probably
have the best run election in the
country in 2022. so a lot of those
things that you've done are called voter
suppression no no yeah I know the left
says that and why is that not voter
suppression so first of all elections
used to be you show up on Election Day
You cast your ballot all this other
stuff is really gone above and beyond
what the original conception of election
even was and so we have a right to
ensure that the people that are showing
up to vote are who they say they are and
that there's no problems with the
process in terms of people voting
multiple times or whatever so what we've
done I think is provide adequate
safeguards where people in Florida can
can feel good that the process has
Integrity but the idea that showing ID
to vote is somehow suppression is insane
when I was active duty in the Navy if
you wanted to come on that navy base you
showed an ID no one said that was
suppression that was just done now all
of a sudden if you don't show an ID to
vote somehow that's suppression it's
nonsense the left wants anything that's
done to ensure the Integrity of the
process wiped away because they want to
be able to exploit gaps in the process
to be able to get their way
I'm going to embellish the point if I
may uh
that we're living in a media mediated
Society now the media is everything
everything and so
if there are people who are going around
Gathering up lots of ballots
the initiative is in them and it's not
in the voter yes and and that means that
you know what we want is to distribute
the authority not collect it among the
powerful
so I
praise you for that well and I mean if
you think about it it's um
what goes into collecting those ballots
what are they doing at the doorstep uh
part of the reason you have a secret
bout is because you don't want to have
any coercion you're in there you're in
that Booth you do it no one knows what
you did well if you have somebody from
like a union showing up to uh union
members family's uh house saying I need
you know where's your ballot well
they're not going to turn that ballot
unless they know you voted the way they
want you to vote so they're they're
going to look at that they're going to
they're going to prod you and actually
you know Jimmy Carter and James Baker
did a report on this I cited it in the
book this is probably 10 20 years ago
where they said when the ballots get out
of the election offices and end up in
people's homes the chance for coercion
and manipulation goes up dramatically
and that's just the basic fact so why
would you want to invite more of that
through ballot harvesting and Zucker
bucks you should want to reduce that and
so that's what we've tried to do in
Florida now I I mean we have you know
short period for early in-person voting
all that I mean I I'd be fine to return
to election day I think the public by
and large likes to have more than one
option and so the legislatures around
the country I don't think any of them
have gone back to just that single day
voting but I mean there is a value of
we're making a collective Choice with
the same information and when you have
some of these states that have early
voting eight weeks before the election
you have people voting for The Campaign
as really even gotten into full swing
and I just don't think that's the the
best thing for the country
that's so good uh James Madison uh
he likes it that
the America he talks about this in the
Federalists the people have influence on
the government and even control of the
government on certain days
and then what they're supposed to do in
the meantime is talk a lot
and then they come to a decision
and then they get together and they're
like a national legislature
and if and you can I have a friend who's
A pollster in California and he tells me
that you can track the polls uh if you
ask people in May
what's the most important thing to them
they'll say I have to remember to pick
up my dry cleaning and if you ask them
in October
they're thinking about the country and
it's governance in other words they got
their minds on it now and that's so I
think we should do the favor of treating
people as if they're thinking people
let's talk about education uh
you first came to my site because we
start charter schools in Florida and
it's the best place uh
and I noticed that uh your team they
would ask us for advice about teaching
things we're teachers around here and we
know how to teach stuff and that it was
easy to give them the advice
and things would happen
uh I thought somebody up there really
knows what they're doing
how do you make all that work I mean
you've described to people what you've
done in Education reform and well one of
the things we did and we really
appreciate Hillsdale helping is the uh
American Civics initiative to get Civics
back in our schools particularly our
high schools in a really big way we got
a private donation of five million
dollars from Bernie Marcus from Home
Depot to start a Civic speech and debate
initiative we're now almost at all 67
counties are participating in that and
we hosted the national championship last
year for that and I think there's value
in that because uh you know you may be a
big Second Amendment guy but you may be
asked to argue the other side of that so
you got to get out of your comfort zone
and vice versa and actually see things
and be able to construct arguments so I
think that one of the things that's been
lost particularly in higher education in
non-hillsdale institutions where the the
Orthodoxy so strong is no one ever
questions these kids assumptions and so
we want to question your assumptions
with that but then the broader issue of
civics there's certain things that you
should have when you leave our school
system you need to have a certain
Foundation to exercise the duty of
American citizenship so part of that's
having good standards we now give the
seniors a citizenship test when they
leave school and they can place out of
civics requirements and higher ed if
they do well we may start to say you
have to pass it to graduate we didn't
want to do that to start because we
didn't fear we feared that the results
wouldn't be that great and they weren't
great they have gotten better but one of
the things we said was you can have the
best standards in the world you need
teachers that really appreciate and
understand the things and so we work
with people from Hillsdale and other top
Scholars to create a 50-hour course for
teachers and so if they go through it
they get a three thousand dollar bonus
what are they learning about they're
learning about the British constitution
they're learning about the Protestant
influence they're learning about all the
intellectual currents that led to the
formation of the American Republic and
then the key episodes that have happened
since then and the people that have
looked at it the teachers that have gone
through it we've got I think 2500
teachers gone through it 89 percent
approval rate and and satisfaction rate
on the course and then people that are
looking at this I had because I meet
with legislators from other states
they're like I cannot believe you guys
actually have you know this you have
Aristotle you have you have play you
have all this stuff that the teachers
are learning like I had one legislative
tell me brought tears to my eyes to see
all this and so but that's really the
foundation that anyone teaching Civics
should have that so we're making the
effort to get this right and to make
sure that our students have an adequate
Foundation
my father was a high school teacher in
Pocahontas Arkansas
and he found his happiness you know
making by the time he finished thirty
four thousand dollars a year as a
teacher I thought it was the greatest
thing and he was a big wheel in our town
uh
when the clintons were elected in
Arkansas she was placed in charge of
Education
and what they started doing was things
that demote the authority of teachers
it's uh you know first of all K-12
education is not rocket science only
rocket science is rocket science
and you know most anybody can do a fair
amount of rocket science if they work
hard enough but everybody can learn to
read well and everybody and so
this idea that there should be authority
over the schools
I mean I I put these numbers together
and they shock me and I'm you know I'm
experienced now I shouldn't be shocked
since 2000 the number of students in the
public schools have grown seven and a
half percent the number of teachers
eight and a half percent
and the number of Administrators 92
percent
that's a massive fact and they're now
more slightly more administrators than
teachers in the school system
and why would that be what's that about
because you know your your solution then
is you help the teachers know
but everybody loves to know and then if
they know then they can teach and that's
and you know it should stop there really
because it's everybody wants to know
well I think in Florida the reason and
we may not have it that Stark with the
admin but but it definitely has grown
here too and a lot of that the majority
of teachers in Florida are actually not
members of the teacher Union
um the majority of the administrator and
other staff vast majority are members
and so when they're bargaining they're
actually putting the teachers in the
back of the line and trying to service
some of the other parts of the school
system at the front of the line so what
I did my second year as Governor is we
because you know we we send money to the
school districts to fund the schools and
then they can negotiate with the unions
or do whatever
um and we're just like you know what we
cannot have this money being put into
Administration so we created What's
called the categorical for just teacher
salaries so we'll give you you know a
billion dollars this year and other
money can be use too but here's a
billion dollars increase each drive it
cannot be used for anything else and so
that really helped a lot of our teachers
and what would happen some of the
districts some of the unions were
holding up the pay raise for the
teachers because they were using that as
leverage to be able to do service some
of the administrative staff and some of
the others and so one of the things
we're doing this legislative session is
doing paycheck protection for for
Teacher unions no automatic deductions
because they give them a form and you
sign the form and it's just authorizing
the deductions but they don't even know
how much money is coming out and of
course when you have multiple deductions
in your paycheck it's easy to get lost
in that now if they want to join they
have a right to join but they've got to
write that check and hand that check to
the union and so if they don't have 60
percent agree to do that then the union
gets decertified and I think the issue
with it is it's been mostly about
advancing partisan politics within our
school system the teacher unions not
defending the right to teach in fact a
lot of these teachers get in trouble
if they just ensure discipline in their
classroom the Union's not not getting
their back the way they should on that
the Union's more concerned about
political correctness and some of the
other things going on so I think Florida
with that reform we are going to
probably be more in line with how
schools have been run historically prior
to a lot of the problems we've seen in
the recent generation
I even think this now I think the growth
of administration I think the temper of
the administrator is different than the
temper of the teacher because if you go
in the classroom that's hard work and if
what you're doing is regulating in some
way from a distance where you never get
in front of the kids
well I think the power of the education
Lobby comes from that class of person
and you know the education Lobby is the
start of the whole Public Employee
regulatory state
so you do something about that you'll do
something good and restore the authority
of the classroom that's that's where it
happens right I mean since
Plato's Academy
20 people 15 people sitting around in a
circle talking that's how Learning
Happens see and we know from the first
line of Aristotle metaphysics everybody
wants to do that
and so
facilitate that good for you one thing
we're doing just uh and I didn't mention
before so we're doing the Civics a big
push important but we also want to give
students a frame of reference to
understanding the American experiment so
we have one day a year November 7th
where students learn about the victims
of Communists and communist regimes and
so they're getting truth about Marxism
leninism they're learning about 100
million dead at the hands of marxist
leninist regimes in the 20th century
alone and that has special reverence in
Florida because we have a lot of people
that have escaped communism probably
have more in our state than any place in
the country and you know you think the
Berlin Wall false you know that you know
it doesn't die it's still there it's in
our hemisphere again in all these other
countries and so we want students to
understand that and have the proper
frame of reference because they go to
most universities they're not learning
about Mao's body count you know with the
with the Great Leap Forward but they
need to know that so you've been making
a fuss about colleges in Florida lately
there's a college in Sarasota and you've
new college and you've changed the board
and you put one of your guys in charge
of it tried to put one of my guys in
charge with it
and you said you said to me you thought
they'd all want to come because they
want to live in the Sun and I said
serious people don't decide where they
live by according to the weather anyway
tell us about that tell us about new
College what you're doing there so it's
interesting so new College when I got
elected governor I didn't know anything
about it uh we had either my first or
second year as Governor the speaker of
the house he's a friend of mine at the
time came and said you know will you get
rid of new college with me I'm like what
is new College he's like well it's down
in Sarasota it's it's like left to the
left they're not doing great and I'm
like yeah that's fine but the
legislature just wouldn't go for that
the people in Sarasota wanted to keep it
and everything so we got that so I'm
like all right well we got to do
something with it and so we looked in
Statute in Florida it's supposed to be
our top Honors College in all of Florida
yet enrollment is cratered test scores
have gone down and it really became
captive to left ideology gender ideology
CRT all this stuff and so my view is you
know a liberal arts university like the
this does not have the right to just do
whatever the heck it wants it's funded
by Florida taxpayers and we have the
right through the people and elections
to set the mission of the University so
we appointed six conservative board
members they fired the president they
hired my former Commissioner of
Education who's a conservative he fired
the Provost they eliminated Dei and CRT
and then they basically said the mission
of this University is to be a classical
liberal arts university and and they
reference Hillsdale College as as uh
something to emulate and so what
happened though is these trustees have
professors from around the country
reaching out saying how do I get to New
College parents are asking how do I
apply and I think it's a function of and
I think hillsdale's benefited from this
Academia has veered so far away from its
traditional Moorings of seeking truth
and teaching people you know how to
think for themselves that it's um it's
almost rare if you have a higher
education embracing a return to truth
and so there's a lot of uh I think
excitement about this now Rome wasn't
built in the day but what we did we
started them off with 15 million dollars
where they can recruit faculty to come
and they've also started a ten thousand
dollar scholarship right we see our
in-state tuition's low it's like 6 500
so the ten thousand dollar scholarship
you'll get the tuition and a lot of
living paid for so it'll be really
really good so they're doing things to
be able to go but I do think it's
something because the school's small
enough where I think we're going to be
able uh to move it in a direction and
here's the thing yes that's what I think
a a college should be doing and that's
the direction but just from a market
opportunity there's all these parents in
the country you see all the people
applying to your University where can I
send my kid without having the
university undo everything I've done for
18 years is what they worry about and so
I think if if new college is one that
they feel confident in that there's
gonna be a lot of people all over the
country that are going to want to apply
there
that's right uh and I want everybody to
realize how magnanimous I am to
advertise the competition but here but I
do think like we we've been uh you know
the Press had a conniption when we did
this I mean I mean look I roll out of
bed they have a conniption but but it
raises the issue for a public
institution uh you know do we have a
right to have accountability in it do we
have a right to set the mission as the
people of Florida through their elected
representatives and I think yes I think
that we absolutely have to make sure
that these universities are serving you
know valid public purposes and to the
extent to which they're being used to
impose ideology or uh support political
activism or quote social justice that's
veering away from what we think is
appropriate and so we're not only doing
the new College we're going to do a
hundred million dollars for the rest of
the University system so that they can
go recruit faculty as well the president
so uh former Senator Ben sass is at
University of Florida he's going to have
money where he's going to be able to go
to George Mason or MIT and say hey if
you come here and teach engineer hearing
we'll pay you this we'll do all that so
we're trying to you know create a
situation where we're attracting good
people and then compensating them for
for doing a good job well I think we're
going to do okay here but I think a lot
of colleges are going to be screaming at
you hey that's not fair you're doing a
good job that's right that's right
uh I I my I want to say a word about
classical education uh what what did
what it has to do with is this it has
two huge advantages
classical learning is the first learning
in the West
and that means it's not about anything
that anybody else said it's about the
things that it's writing about the first
book of history is called the histories
by Herodotus the name wasn't taken first
book of Ethics is called the ethics by
Aristotle so you can go back to the
beginning and then the second thing is
you can step outside your time
you know the people who give uh
in school people give young people the
advice you should follow the news every
day
I tell not to you know you should learn
what things mean you see and that's
liberating
and then one of the things you learn if
you study the classics is nobody ever
learned a single thing except as a
volunteer
you can't you can deprive students of
information
you can't make them know anything
so these people I mean all you're doing
is introducing some diversity in this
uniformity that calls itself diversity
but all the other stuff that that would
be uh replacing so much of that just
intellectual empty calories I mean like
if it really had value it may be
different for me politically but fine
but a lot of it isn't a lot of that is
more of kind of spirit of the age stuff
and the stuff you're talking about you
know that has stood the test of time and
that's something that gives people a
foundation for the rest of their lives
how think all this
would play on the national
well I mean I think it depends on on
what part of what we've discussed I mean
I think that uh clearly I think parents
are more concerned about education than
ever been before now Federal
government's role in that is different
than what our role in Florida has been
or even on the school boards we work to
elect a lot of school board members
throughout Florida which has been good
but one of the things we're looking to
do in Florida and with other states and
we would need the federal government to
approve this for the doe is have a an
accreditor that can have a process and
have criteria that is more in line with
how we believe a university should run
and right now that's not really there
and of course that reply you guys don't
take the money which is smart but a lot
of these others have done it so to be
able to have that this Administration
wouldn't approve it but the next one
probably would that could really I think
open up some positive things because
there are some of these universities
that say look I don't want to do a lot
of this but the accreditor is going to
ding me if I don't don't do it well if
we have Florida Texas Georgia Tennessee
having a different accreditor and that
goes in a republican Administration a
democratic Administration not going to
be able to come in and undo that because
there's too many institutions that will
be at stake in that point so I think in
terms of higher education reform I do
think there's some things that can be
done with accreditation
let's go back to the the general for a
minute
at the grandest level
yours is a book about the
misarrangements of power in America
there are three branches executive
legislative and judicial and they're not
doing their jobs and much of their job
has been delegated to a fourth thing
and what you're calling for is
to arrange it the way it's supposed to
be
and that means the Congress has to make
the laws and the president has to
execute the laws and the courts have to
judge according to the laws now that's a
tall order that's a big thing and you
give some examples of things you do to
make that stronger in Florida uh
the most exciting thing that I schedule
F
but the veto the line item veto those
things
do you think that somebody
do you think a movement can start it it
obviously is going to have to affect all
the branches of government it's going to
involve millions of people
but it's sort of like uh
walking back one of the great
transformations in American history
in world history
in 1890 the government was eight percent
of the gross domestic product
and almost all of it was in cities and
towns
now it's 52 53 percent
and it's centralized can that be walked
back I think it's difficult but I think
it can be just because I think people
have have seen the contradictions in
more recent years probably more than in
in in previous generations and I think
the fact that the the power has been
exercised in a very sharp weaponized
fashion has caused more Americans to
take this very very seriously and really
want to see some some significant change
now it will require the executive who's
very disciplined about about pursuing
this case and it would probably take
many many years it will require key
people in the administration at the
secretary and deputy secretary level
then it would require thousands of
people to be in kind of the bowels of
the bureaucracy who were serious about
reconstitutionalizing government so so
it's a big project now one of the things
we did in Florida was you know we had a
very liberal state supreme court four to
three liberal split when I took office
three of the four liberals had to retire
because of retirement age I put three
conservatives on we changed the court
for a generation we now have I would say
a
six to three loose U.S Supreme Court I
don't think that the six are always
Dependable I think we've got two that
are 100 percent and I think the others
are varying degrees but I think you have
a court in place now uh based off the
the Trump appointments that would be
receptive uh to upholding some of the
actions uh that we discussed which would
probably not have been the case 10 years
ago so that's another good thing and
then I think the missing ingredient is
how serious is Congress going to be
about this if you're only uh priority is
to avoid any quote government shutdown
then you're never going to be willing to
use the leverage that you need to to
rein in the administrative state
what leverage do they the power of the
purse they can simply not fund uh
offending conduct or if there's if
there's agencies that are abusing the
people's rights that's what that's why
Madison said it was the most potent
weapon that that the people's
Representatives can be armed with
because at the end of the day an
executive if you do like if this if the
left Florida legislature deprived me of
funding for one of my agencies I
physically can't do anything with that
agency at that point uh or if they
curtail it or limit the funding only to
certain specified activities then you're
running afoul the law if you violate
that so so that's really I think key and
then also the law making function stop
delegating decisions to the bureaucracy
your Congress you make a determination
but this is all I mean it started you
know with Wilson and all these other
people over a hundred years but the idea
that only experts can run government
that oh you know Congress can't possibly
make these decisions so let's just give
a blanket grant of authority to the EPA
so that it's constantly legislating
things that have a profound effect on
the American economy and can be
interpreted differently depending on
whether you have a Democrat or
Republican Administration they have
ceded the law making power uh which is
kind of the the twin of the power of the
purse in terms of those are the two
functions of Congress and they don't
want to exercise either of them well
Governor uh I have watched you be
governor and I never saw anybody better
at it uh and you have a plan for the
country and I want to thank you for
coming on this podcast it's a proud
thing to inaugurate it with you godspeed
thank you